that's what sort of second term
president did you do you want Obama to
become if he wins re-election that's a
great question because I was gonna talk
about the drug war that was a big story
in the paper this week about the drug
war there was a commission from from
some flaming liberals like George Shultz
remember George Shultz he's got to be a
hundred and ten serves a big pat on the
back because this Commission basically
said I loved it they phrased it this way
they said politicians should do publicly
what they acknowledge privately because
I've heard so many politicians as soon
as the cameras off they will say to you
yes to drug war is a failure that's not
the way to handle it they said just
acknowledge what you tell us
in private publicly you know they into
more conservatives have spoken out on it
you know lately it's true absolutely but
anyway to get to the point of the
question I'm hoping that this is one of
those things that Obama knows he can't
touch in his first term but in his
second term he might touch something
like the drug war wait a bit in the
first term which is to say that he did
he did pass a sign legislation that
equalized the crack and powder cocaine
situation which really was having an
enormous it's still enormously disparate
impact so it's not as though he hasn't
touched this at all but certainly he
hasn't he as the african-american
president being called a non-american
and given that both crime and welfare
have been so racialized since the 1980s
as ideas the idea that the black guy
would come in and say okay you know
we're done with crime you know with with
the drug right now it's very sort of
like nas if I ruled the world you just
can't really do that no I know but I do
feel kind of bad for the guy who's
rotting in prison who heard first and
can't do it because Clinton has a sex
problem so we can't be the guy who's
getting blown and also once the smoked
pot and now Obama can't be the guy on
black and I also like when can a guy
come into office
Nixon could have been in haight-ashbury
the problem is is that if so long as
there are hack politicians who want to
say three-strikes-you're-out
and come out with your slogan they're
not thoughtful I think we need to like
actually push them further I think we
need to be even worse than
three-strikes-you're-out I think it has
to be like charged the mound you're out
so it's only one time I think it has to
be like mmm a tap out you're out like
you know even worse I think to can't
like you can't have one-size-fits-all on
this because there are some people that
are violent they have violent
backgrounds and II be treated
differently I'm totally for no drug
courts work we know prevention works but
there are some people that are gonna be
recidivist they're gonna be on the
street and the reason why crime has been
coming down violent crime has been
coming down in America and it's defied
the odds because as the economy
deteriorates generally right you see
more violent people are saying one of
the studies says is because of the fact
that well we do put more people in jail
than any others for the most part I mean
it's mostly nonviolent drug so either
were the greatest people in the world or
were the people who somehow put more of
our people in jail how can we still be
the grass we're not the greatest people
no but there's a million in jail we have
two men in jail which percentage-wise is
more than China more than anyone and we
also are one of the only four countries
in the world that put people children to
death and we also put learning disabled
people to death which is [ __ ] up if
you really think about that
[Applause]
although the build point though it goes
the bills point about about private
industry I mean we've privatized it yes
so that prisons are profit driven and
anything that's profit driven is gonna
put more people in it that's because
that's how they're making their money so
what we've done is we've said okay if we
take this whole group of people and
incarcerate them then they're not
looking for work that will drop the
unemployment rate and by the way all
these unskilled workers who don't who
don't have jobs building bridges will
put them to work guarding the other guys
and so downstate Illinois ends up making
jobs for uncle Dwight with workers and
locking up unskilled black workers and
therefore you start creating some jobs
and there's no votes for tipper to
combat alcoholism in progress you know
that's the reality right you know you've
met the enemy it's us it doesn't know
who's coming out that's right talk about
you know alcoholism if even after all
these years is a plague and people still
don't want to talk about it and you know
what studies by the way that's asking
this question you're right they're
sociologists are baffled why the crime
rate went down even in a recession
because usually it goes up the theory
was well people are poor they were out
of work they have to rob you you know
what it is they stopped putting lead in
paint yeah that's one kids stop eating
paint chips with lead and that makes
them violence something as simple as
that just not making kids violent well
no I'm not getting full disclosure I own
three private prisons myself I gotta
tell you we employ a lot of good people
yes we abuse some prisoners but yeah
just think of the big picture that's all
I'm saying is this is a question I was
about to ask and we didn't get to it is
Germany making the right choice in their
decision to abandon nuclear power this I
think is really interesting Germany
unlike this country can gather in new
information adapt and then change their
ways that's completely foreign to us
but sure I think when when Germany the
most technically advanced people ever
yes you know when they say hey you know
what this ain't worth it nuclear power
okay but not so cool you know because
you know what's been happening in
Germany coal prices have been spiking
because they're thinking they're gonna
replace nuclear power which is non
carbon emitting with with coal which is
highly dirty so you know people every
wants to go to heaven but they don't
want to die so they don't want nuclear
power they don't want a get that drill
for natural gas
I don't want transmission lines I don't
think Germany's plan is to go back to
coal I was just in actually we're
shooting a movie right now in Berlin and
I was there for two weeks and it's crazy
driving around that country because you
see two things you see giant windmills
everywhere you see solar power
everywhere and you also see factories
and we kept laughing like oh my god they
make their own shoes here they make
their own belts they didn't outsource
everything and and not only that they're
a very profitable country and they have
a great sort of equal distribution of
wealth they have health care I talked to
my driver which sounds really gross but
I talked to my driver about it and he
described how unemployment works that if
you can't get a job
you go through tier two tier two tier to
find a job and then if you can't get one
they give you a dollar a day and you
clean up by the side of the road but you
get unemployment and they have a big
government big government ginormous
people do something they expect people
who wonder which that's the contract
liberals are fine with that yeah I don't
think that's I don't know come on listen
I think if that was really on the table
I think when I when I was in Congress I
had in a public housing reform bill you
know the people who were getting aid
getting help not paying any rent at all
weren't students weren't taking care of
a parent that was sick all these
exemptions that give seven hours a month
to their community to their building to
whatever they wanted me to
it was a polarizing there but I
no more for the idle rich for whom you
gave enormous tax cuts what is if you're
rich underwrite your idleness but
goodbye to secure warning or you make
the learning shoe for being a
stay-at-home mother still needed
literate there but the first thing all
right you've already talked thank you